in Vegas people always seem to say area
51 don't say that
what Benihana it's Benihana the that
kind of grill place where they chop it
and throw up in the air right where
everybody thinks they can wear Gucci
shoes inside it's not their slogan
Benihana where everyone thinks they can
wear Gucci shoes inside anyone from
Benihana marketing in I've found you a
new campaign okay I mean I'll take that
suggestion I'm gonna be the extra final
rule which is if I've had the suggestion
before I'll be honest with you I'll say
I've had that I don't do the same ones
twice the best thing ever was ninth
century crop rotation that was good
in the last show some guy down front was
like a Clockwork Orange there's a great
suggestion he hadn't either seen the
film nor read the book so he was just
fronting vina maybe you haven't been to
Benihana I don't know so Benihana where
people think they can wear Gucci shoes
inside is the first suggestion that's
come from over here so what kind of move
here what you want to wrap bad people
here colonialism now feels slightly
obvious suggestion but obviously
[Laughter]
what let's pick an aspect of colonialism
that we can really kind of drill down
into powdered wigs that was a lovely
whisper yeah now I heard that
colonialism but really powdered wigs I
think it's you know them the main the
main negative outcome of colonialism was
awful head worth so ok Benihana whop
your work Gucci shoes powdered wigs in
colonial times and colonialism this
section here which one wrap that what
crop circles fits in with Benihana what
what I know a bean to Benihana but I've
no idea
crop circles guys over here
stranger things cool yeah I'll let me
what's the kind of acceptable amount of
plot to reveal I'm gonna okay will only
include up to season the end of season
two maybe I think season four is coming
out pretty soon and I feel like you
should have had time to do up to season
two also it's the only season I've seen
up to so there we go
okay so Benihana where people think they
can wear Gucci shoes crop circles
powdered wigs and colonialism stranger
things and let's get one final one but
like this one one second I'm going to
come to you in a moment sexy bald black
man
I'm just gonna just check what this this
one which definitely is not as good as
the phrase sexy bald black man I'm just
gonna give her an opportunity acceded to
say it first what was it Waffle House
I'm sorry No
[Music]
okay so we have Benihana where people
think they can work Gucci shoes inside
colonialism and powdered wigs stranger
things crop circles and a sexy bald
black men which I mean the lights are
down low but I assume you're not a
skinny white guy this then lovely people
at the company seller to kind of close
out the night to bring shut the [ __ ] up
to bring this show that's not even a
suggestion that's just a heckle just
English [ __ ] man this is gonna
be a freestyle rap that has a rap made
up on the spot based entirely on those
suggestions it's not written down it's
not rehearsed it's not prepared none of
this will ever be seen again and don't
worry it won't be anywhere near as bad
as you're expecting it to be if we can
drop that beat friend let's serve some
fun with this I'm excited I'm excited
it's gonna be good it's gonna be good
let's we'll start with you
[Music]
date night what my I do I open it all up
my closet look the Gucci shoes I got the
big G wear it down there and I hope to
rock up to Benihana and show my loafers
that don't take above the door I'm not a
man living in the whole cities inside
Japan that's what they do there I like
to be the best I'm in Benihana a sharp
knife chef you can see me dropping up to
me my thrills when I flipped on the
blade like a pancake grill chopping all
the veggies and all this is that troll
and then I'm server up Wow is just so so
precise a chop an egg with the cleaver
is kind of taking neither ball much
easier but not as flashy as cracking it
in the air if you travel 1,800 take care
if you're not British and white they
will look at you and say why do you not
have a nice buckle - you need to buck up
your ideas give your pot ship air take a
powdered wig yes
off we go we into there we write a nice
big boat take in the air we're going to
plunder all of the spices put your wig
on straight yeah that's my advice is
just ignore all of the for the people
that we murder is lost as you've got a
nice little curl there make sure the
powder is fresh and you've got to go to
bloom butter on your chest basically
that's all we need to discuss about
I press it lay it down while Kitson in
the top you've seen signs the Shyamalan
movie they put the crops down later
circular smoothie aliens from space down
there you go they make a geometric shape
in the UFO but technically that [ __ ] is
a load of wank it's a conspiracy it's
done by a rope and the plank you just
pull that round stand in the sheaves
make sure you don't tread it down with
your feet it's so damn amazing when the
props plan let me tell you what stranger
things have happened than a retro show
ripping off John Carpenter going on
Netflix now it's not the season for how
many more maybe seven like the main
character that will be 11 yeah numbers
out I really go to the yard ride a bike
with the hack to fin wall pod and all
the other guys the small black dude and
Nikki was older and tried to improve his
weight lift in and lost his hair he
would be like this guy
in his chair he was just in being
friends with Dustin so damn rip that
shirt is busted he is so sexy he won't
be allowed to eat any waffles if he went
to a house he won't be there yes they
and coffin I'm [ __ ] your luck my
name's Mary Poppins makes no sense sexy
black backs all of the family working
for mr. banks here is how we do it is
fun to nice and play that's the end of
the freestyle rap for y'all today
[Applause]
[Music]